M: Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Don't Starve
M: Remember how we said we weren't gonna - uh...
M: we-we're gonna be right back where we were?
M: Well, we tried! It didn't work! We died. A lot. It was bad.
M: So-
M: Here.. yeah. Bob?
B: Uh- yeah. It's g- no, I don't know why you're hedging. It went- it's going so well.
M: Yeah!
B: Everything - it's all - it's- this is perfectly the plan.
M: Yeah so you might be confused-
B: Hey buddy! Hey hey - I found you!
M: Heyyy! Yeah - you might be confused as to where we are,
M: So let me show you, uhh, a short few minute montage
M: of our getting to this point, including what happened when we tried to get our stuff back.
B: How close - how close are we to the thingy?
M: We're very close, okay.
B: I-Is it time for the evasive maneuvers n' shit?
M: Hell yeah - it's really just the hornets, here they come.
B: I have two on me.
M: Yeah cut through this way...
Okay.
M: Go round - ooh back off! Ah, okay - ow! Ooh one got me!
B: Oh, oh jeez, oh shit.  OH JEEZ THERE'S SO MANY -- I'm dead again.
M: Holy shit, you're dead again? Oh boy
B: Oh my god
M: Ohhh
B: My sister's ghost is here getting the shit stung out of her by hornets!
M: Aaah! Oh, Jesus! Oh there's so many! Oh this was a horrible error!
B: *Little smirk* Why are we here?!
M: Welp!
B: Well.. I think we're fucked
B: Hiii, friend!
*playful music starts playing*
M: Hello!
M: I think there might be beefalo
M: That's like a beefalo area north.. north-west right?
B: Oh hey wormhole
M: Let's jump in!
M: Oh this didn't go anywhere far away, this is a stupid wormhole
M: Wait this is a desert, this is not where we wanna be
M: I don't think - I don't think we should be here
M: Oh there's no beefalo anywhere!
M:  THIS IS A DEAD END ALSO!
M: What if a-at the end of the desert, it's like an oasis of beefalo?
M: It's a dead eeeeeenndddd...
B: Please be a dead end..
M: OH THIS WAS A MISTAAAAAAAAAKE!!
B: Oh, *laughter* Shit!
M: Oh this is a dead end too - good god I am the worst..
B: *laughter* What, why is this like this?!
M: I don't know! There's usually beefalo!
B: Where are the goddamn beef —  ?
M: It's probably another dead end over there...
M: Welp, looks- looks dead end-ish..
B: Oh it's so dead
M: Oh jeez
M: Ooh jeez
M: Oooh jeez
M: It's just a big peninsula
B: Goddamn, really?!
M: Gonna turn into a dead eeend.. it's a dead eeend, it's a dead end, it's a dead end.
B: Goddamn, what the fuck?
M: Wasn't that fun? :D Okay.. alright..
Hey look it's day!
B: Thank God
M: Okay so we're-
B: Let's go in this wormhole!
M: Let's go in this wormhole, indeed!
M: Okay so if you, uh, are curious as to what we're doing in this episode
M: It's interesting, we were trying to find some beefalo and we went literally everywhere.
M: Uh, not literally everywhere - we went a lot of "where"s and just couldn't find beefalo!
M: So... but what we did find was something that we've never seen before, ever.
M: And we have no idea what it is.
So we're gonna go try to fight it!
B: Super cool.
M: Yeah, so, we were around here in this like, lava area?
M: Oh it's moving!
B: Oh,
B: Oh my god...
M: Oh it's moving!
M: Oh it's moving! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
M: Hello?
M: Howdy- HOOHHHKAY!
B: I am here to barter with you -
B: OH MY GOD IT'S COMING FOR ME :O
M: Oh Jesus!
B: Oh my god!
M: It does not like you!
M: OH MY GOD YOU'RE DEAD!
B: Uhhhm...
M: HOW ARE YOU DEAD?
B: It... (unclear) ...me
M: OWW!
M: It hurts so bad!
B: It does a lot of damage.
M: Aaah, Gaw-hawd! *laughing* Oh Jesus!
B: Oh, I get it,
B: I get it, it's called a
B: "DRAGON-FLY"
M: Ohhhhh my Gawwwwd, okay
B: It's call- it's call- it's a-
B: It's called a "DRAGON-FLY"
M: It's a "dragon-fly"...
B: It's called a "dragon-fly"..
M: Alright so, there's a cool thing, uh, that we're gonna show you.
M: It's called:
M: Starting ANOTHER world
M: And *laughs*
trying to find beefalo.
B: HAHA!!!!
B: Fuck this game man!
M: Oh man, we gotta do it, we gotta do it!
M: We gotta do it man!!
M: WE GOTTA DO IT
M: I'm gonna start a new server, we're gonna have beefalo RIGHT THERE
B: There will not be, okay..alright
M: I PROMISE!! I PROMISE!!!
M: If-If-If there aren't, If there AREN'T, IF THERE AREN'T
B: I'm rage-quitting and, never playing this game again
M: I...
M: Uh,
M: Okay...
B: *laughs* No pressure, Mark!
M: Oh.
B: Just do good!
M: 'Kay
B: Are you just gonna adjust the settings so that we spawn into a Utopia like that one time?
M: I don't have any settings like that now
M: Oh yes I do!
B: *laughs*
B: *inhales* Everything, everywhere, so that it is so crowded, that you can't even put anything down.
B: Fuck it
M: But I'm not gonna do that because I tell you,
M: I tell YOU,
M: I TELL you,
B: I TELL you!
M: There's gonna be beefalo
M: I'm generating the world right now
M: You're gonna see man, you're gonna see!
B: Okay...
*sighs*
M: Beefalo EVERYWHERE like..
B: uh huh, uh huh
M: ...THEY'RE FUCKIN' IN EVERY CORNER...
B: Uh huh, uh huh
M: ...OF THIS WORLD THEY'RE MAKIN MORE BEEFALO BABIES
M: IT'S JUST BEEFALO OUT THE ASS
M: EVERYWHERE YOU LOOK IT'S- OH MY GOD IT'S LIKE TOO MANY BEEFALO!
B: Mhmm
M: It's so many beefalo that you can't even KILL a beefalo because the OTHER beefalo will kill you
B: Mhm, no I'm comin', don't worry
M: That's what it's gonna be like
B: It's happenin'
M: TRUST ME
B: It's gonna be awesome
M: Trust me dude!
M: Trust ME dude
B: I dude, this is me trusting you.
B: This is full trust.
M: Me dude-eh-trust...
M: Trust...
B: I'm in, I'm all the way in right now...
B: Alright I just spawned in.
M: Me dude-eh-trust...
M: Look
M: It's a field
M: It's a field!
B: Yeah. Yeah yeah, that's a start,
B: That's a start
M: Oh yeah! Dude, when I promise, I deliver!
M: And when I deliver...
M: Uh- I- Jus- ...
B: Remember what the deal was
if there are no beefalo right near spawn.
M: Oh jeez it's clock work - aaaa...
B: That seems good.
M: That- it- Okay it may not seem like beefalo right now...but
M: Just give...
B: Yeah, no I'm still- I'm still with you.
M: .. to the North-West. This way.
B: There's still some- Yeah
M: A slightly na- unnavigated.
M: I-i-it means a lot that your faith in me is well placed.
B: Full, full faith.
M: Yes, please.
B: (indiscernible)
M: Okay.
B: You can do this.
M: Okay, umm.
M: Ahh see there's ano- look it's another, it's another uhh...
M: It's another field biome
B: Oh yeah that, that's the one
B: That's the one.
M: Ow! Fucking horny toad.
B: What the hell is fucking happening
M: This fucking toad. Alright forget that!
B: Ouch. Oh not you toad. Not like this.
M: Ow they really hurt...okay I- not gunna... do that.
M: They steal your stuff too
M: Okay this is not a big...
M: There was uhhhh
B: *giggles*
M: Okay...
B: Sooooo
M: Uhhhh
M: Oh fuck, it's more clock work stuff.
M: WHAT IS GOING ON?!
B: Uhh... 'kay well...
M: Wait hang on
B: Well, you know what? I'm not giving up yet.
I still have faith in you
M: Alright cool...This is a dead end.
*Mark's axe talks in background*
M: W- Uhmm-
M: They can be in a rocky area, right?
B: I still have faith in you, man, I still-
B: Don't- don't give up, man.
B: Don't give up.
M: They- they could be in a rocky area, I'm pretty sure.
B: Yeah, maybe they changed beefalo habitats, yeah.
M: I've heard rumors that you could have beefalo in a-
M: This'a graveyard...
B: Maybe they added species.
B: It's- It's "rock beefalo".
M: Rock- "Rockalo".
M: Maybe they took beefalo out of the game...? :)
B: *laughs for an uncomfortable amount of time*
M: Why did we need beefalo, anyway?!
M: It's your unhealthy obsession with beefalo
that caused us to do this!
B: You need - you need -
B: You need beefalo poop to make things like farms
B: Or cooking stuff
M: That's true...
B: To grow things...
M: Wh-what about our poop?
M: Can we use that?
M: Well, we gotta do something! This can't be an episode without something!
B: *laughing* I think I'm just gonna cut it off when you finally give up on the notion of finding beefalo
M: NO!
B: *still laughing*
M: There's fuckin' beefalo out there!
M: Ah, god dammit
B: I'm sure there are somewhere
M: Just-- *sighs*
B: Just nowhere that we've ever looked yet
M: Yes, that's true, so we need to k--
M: This is another dead end, good god!
M: It's just nothing but dead ends!
B: *laughing again*
M: Such bullshit...
M: Why?!
B: It's--*still laughing*
M: Why??
B: Were you going--Were you going straight south?
B: Oh wow...
M: I don't know where I'm going now, I'm just going everywhere
B: *laughing again*
M: There's GOTTA be...
M: I'm gonna find 'em for ya...
M: I'm gonna find 'em for ya!
M: And you're finally gonna respect me.
B: I respect you, whaddya mean finally gonna respect you?
M: You're finally gonna respect me as a human being
B: ...
B: I have plenty of...respect for you as a human being
M: I-I sense the air quotes when you said respect.
B: I said it like that, but I didn't actually do air quotes.
M: Oh, okay
B: You can check the footage
M: *mumbling* Alright, okay, alright then
B: But no, I have lots of respect for you
M: *still mumbling* Oh, okay, alright then
B: Hey, I found beefalo! :D
M: You're lying, you're lying to me.
B: N--I am lying, there are no beefalo.
M: You're lying.
M: This is the one time I finally learn not to trust your lies.
B: Wow, after all this time
B: when I say I found beefalo in a completely meaningless round of Don't Starve Together,
B: That's when you decide it's time to start challenging the truths I tell.
M: It's not meaningless.
B: It's--It's a little bit meaningless if we can't find beefalo *laughs*
M: We CAN. Beefalo isn't everything, but
M: We can
B: Oh, I--wait, wait, I found a grass biome...
M: ... *trying not to get hopes up* okay...
B: uh huh, uh huh, uh huh...
B: It's not, it hasn't ended yet...uh huh...
B: Alright it ended, it's a dead end
M: *disappointed sigh*
B: It's almost impressive
M: *another sigh*
M: *and another sigh*
B: I mean, impressive's the wrong word
M: Okay, okay
B: It's almost...enough to make me question whether this is worth it
M: Okay, lemme make one more game
B: What, it just--Just make a new one? *laughs*
M: Just ONE more! Come on, just one more!
M: It w--You've got fi--four minutes left
B: You've got four minutes left
B: I will only allow this...
B: If you--if you make, uh...
B: If you sing "A Whole New World"
B: While it's loading in
M: Okay
M: I can do that
M: I'll do that for you
B: I'll sing Jasmine's part
B: As much, as far as I know, I don't really know it that well, but
M: Okay...hang on, I gotta make this
M: *typing*
M: And everyone can see I'm not doing this like, I'm not upgrading the things
M: okay
M: Alright, alright
B: Check out for edits
B: There might be some edits (indiscernible)
M: There's no edits
M: This is completely uncut
M: Including the singing
B: Watch out for (indiscernible), watch out for speedy edit
M: Alright
M: *starts singing* I can show you the world...
B: No, you have to sing it happy! You can't sing at me angrily
M: *starts singing with forced smile* I can show you the world...
M: Shining, bl-uh, that's not the right...phrase there
B: *starts laughing*
M: *throws in some dancing?* Something da da duh daa da
M: On a magic carpet ride
M & B (out of sync): A whole new world!
M & B: ....
B: No, you have to sing his part
M: What--
B: You really don't know that song?
M: I thought--
M: No, Ja-Jasmine comes in there
B: Jasmine goes *more off key singing* "A whole new wor--"
B: And then you go *singing* "Don't you dare close your eyes!"
M: Oh, "Don't you dare close your eyes!"
M: It--the game's loaded, so f--*laughs*
B: *laughs*
M: Just get in 'ere!
B: Are you really--
B: You really fuckin' wanna find some beefalo
B: *laughing*
M: I want the beefalo!
B: *still laughing*
M: *sighs*
M: There's a--There's a dead body with some boards by us.
B: ...
B: Is that beefalo?
M: That's not beefalo
M: It's--It's boards
B: Okay
M: Okay
B: It's close
M: *sighs*
M: Th--I swear, this one's gonna have beefalo.
B: Alright.
B: Did you go north or south?
M: I wen' north
M: Kinda northwest-ish
B: Alright.
B: I'm gonna go south.
B: We--we're gonna, let's do this...let's do this from all angles. ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
M: Okay. Alright
M: And don't go like *mockingly* "OHH BEEFALO" and, you know, until
M: there's actually beefalo
B: South...south is a dead end
M: Okay, there's a grass--
B: I already did--
B: I already did the "Oh, I found beefalo--" Wow, it's a complete dead end like two seconds from our spawn.
B: Wow, fuck, really?!
M: What's a juicy berry bush?
M: Wut?
B: Where am I supposed to go??
B: There's a dead end...
B: South and straight west from our spawn *laughs*
M: Jeezus...
M: I found a juicy berry bush, I don't know what that is
B: It's just like a really, really quality berry bush.
M: Apparently.
M: Oh, I found a--an eye bone, I can get Chester!
B: Oh, nice!
M: Chester! :3
B: That'll be useful
M: Yay, okay, that's helpful
M: *quietly cries* It's not beefalo though...
M: *sniffs* There he is, there's Chester
B: *laughing in the background*
M: Hi, Chester
B: What's this--
B: What's this game called?
B: "Just Find the Beefalo for Fuck's Sake"?
M: *laughs sadly*
M: *sniffs* That's funny, man...
M: That's really funny... ;(
B: "Don't--Don't Forget to Not Find the Beefalo"?
B: Seriously! We started on a fucking closed off peninsula, are you shittin' me??
M: *elongated sigh*
B: West to south and east are all complete dead ends, you have to go north for like a long time to get out of here.
M: Oh no...
M: What's a mandrake?
B: Also, in the--
M: Is that thing gonna knock me out?
B: Uhhh...maybe?
*mandrake cries*
M: *already picked it anyway* uh oh
M: Oh wow
M: Oh my god
M: This mandrake, that was really sad *laughs*
B: *laughing* What happened?
M: I dunno, it just, it popped out of the ground it gave like a pathetic little cry and then it died.
(r.i.p. mandrake)
B: Wow
M: Geez...
B: Oh my god, why is there so many fuckin' horny toad douchebags?!
B: What is a--hey, it's a juicy berry bush!
M: Yeah! That's what I found
M: Weird...
B: WHA--AHH FUCK YOU FROG
M: I know, right?
M: Frogs are douches.
B: So....
M: *groaning* Ohhh no...
B: How's the beefalo hunt comin'?
M: *louder groaning* Ohhhh nooo....
B: *laughing*
M: *softer groaning again* ohhh no....
B: I-- *sighs*
B: I...
B: *sighs*
M: Oh--*glimmer of hope* OH!
M: *howler monkey impression*
M: I FOUND IT!! I FOUND IT!! FAR EAST!
M: FOLLOW THE ROAD EAST!
M: If you go north a little bit out of that peninsula and then follow the road all the way east
M: *takes a breath*
M: *sing-songy* OHHHHHHHH I FFFOOOOOOUND IIIIT!
M: Yyess!
M: Okay...
M: You won't believe me until you get here
B: *laughing*
M: You won't believe me until you get here, you got to...
B: *laughing* I don't believe you, I don't...
M: go north from spawn, go around that little crevasse,
M: And then head east. East til you find a road
B: I still don't believe you *laughs*
M: It's kinda like a southeastern road.
B: Mhm, mhm...
M: And it may just--NO THERE'S MORE THAN THAT, OHHH THERE'S A LOT O' BEEFALO HERE
M: I'm gonna chop wood, we're gonna make camp! Ooooh! It's gonna be so goood..
M: Ohhh it's gonna be so good.. ;)
B: It's evening now, so I hope it's not too far away.
M: No, it's, you'll make it.
B: Oh my god.
M: ....
M: That's...Don't--Don't do that
B: There's.........There's three.....There's three beefalos lookin' at me
M: *excited* Wait, where??
B: I'm...on the...I'm on a road that's going sorta northeast
M: ...
M: Northeast?
B: Oh! I think I'm southeast of you.
M: Okay...
B: I think you went way further....
B: ..north than I did.
M: Yeah.
B: And I am southeast of you currently in the same grasslands, cause there's a northwesterly road,
B: That I'm currently travelling on.
M: Okay, I'm coming to that grassland.
M: If--On the--On the western border...
M: Of that grasslands, you see a forest, with PINE trees, right?
B: I can't see the western border, but at the southern border where I entered, there was a forest with pine trees.
M: Okay, I'm coming back...
M: Wait a minute...
M: Oh no!
M: You're in a different--You're in a different one!
B: Oh...
M: Well, okay, we--
B: Now there's too many beefalo?!
M: Yeah, we--we found many beefalo, okay but this is good!
M: Right?!
B: How is--
B: How is THIS good?
M: I--I don't know...oh, I don't know, okay, like...
M: On my map...
M: If you look at the diamond hashes...
M: My guy is exactly
M: Four and a half dashes to the right
M: And then one HALF s--like...
M: Diamond south of the spiral stawn--spawn point
M: That's where my guy is.
B: Oh, shit, shit! Shit! Shit!
B: Shit! Shit! *Bob is panicking*
M: That doesn't--oh, it's night, yeah
B: It's nighttime! Fuck!
M: Do you not have...
B: I have a torch...
M: Okay...
M: That'll have to do
B: So... where is the spiral spawn?
B: What are you talking about, spawn?
M: Okay...
M: If you look on the map...
B: Wait, you're south of the spawn?
B: That's where you are?
M: That's where I am.
B: I'm way the fuck far north of you..
B: I'm straight north of you, like...
B: Ten or fifteen diamonds.
M: WWWHAT??!!
M: ...Wait, how zoomed out...
M: How zoomed out are you? Wait, ah, I forgot this could zoom in and out.
B: Oh Jesus lord.
M: Which changes the entire dynamic of it.
B: Jimminy Crapmas...
M: God dammit!
B: Uh, well I'm certainly way further north than you're describing,
M: Okay...
B: Cause I am
B: I am almost straight north--I'm like north--barely northeast of the spawn,
B: And I walked--That's the only direction that I walked
M: Okay...
B: So I'm like a lot that direction
M: So head back towards spawn,
Mark: Or, I'll... *kill you >:3*
M: How did we get separated?
B: You should go north, and, you have an axe already, right?
M: Yeah
B: You should go north and collect resources on the way.
B: All I have is like grass.
M: Okay, I'm comin'
B: And I will start collecting beefalo poops,
M: Okay.
B: And try and start trapping rabbits.
B: And, and doing that sort of stuff.
M: Okay...
M: This is a plan, and then once we get together, then we'll be golden, we can stop...
M: The episode and everything will be cool..
M: Right?
B: That'll be the conclusion, our--our reuniting?
M: Yeah. W-won't it?
M: Wait...
B: That'll be good.
M: Okay, so you're directly north of the spawn..?
B: I'm directly north of it...basically.
M: So did you have to cross a pine forest to get to that grassland?
B: I...think so?
M: And is there a stone road..
M: That you had to go through?
B: Yes, I used a stone road that went sort of northeast
B: To go up into the grassland
M: Oh, and it's really zigzaggy?
B: Yes
M: Okay...Okay
M: I'm on the right path...
B: Yes, it's super zigzaggy, and it has like...
M: IIIIII seeeeee.....
M: *singing* BEEFALOOOOO!! Where are you?
B: I am, uh....
B: Oh, shit, I might be isolated right now.
B: I went north exploring, and....nope, okay.
B: I'm--I'm connected.
M: Kay, I'm not seein' you, but I need to get more wood, so...
B: Are you in the grasslands right now?
M: Uhh, yeah, I'm just at the swamp edge of it.
B: Alright...
M: I should have gotten more trees on the way up.
B: Did you follow the road over there?
M: Yeah, I'm...
M: following the road back down to get some trees
M: Cause there's-
B: I'm comin'.
M: I didn't realize there were no trees up here.
B: I'm on the road
B: Oh no, I'm at the swamp edge of it, fuck.
M: Kay, so you're--you're right near me, but I'm just goin' into the pine forest,
M: and getting some trees.
B: This "reunitation" is gonna be so epic. :)
M: It's gonna be like...orgasmic. (Oooh :])
B: Alright, I'm back down in the...pine...forest area..?
B: No, I'm not, I'm in the swamp.
M: Wait, you--you're comin' to me?
M: I was gonna come to you when I'm done getting wood.
.....
B: Why--That sounds like your own private personal business, but I--I'll...
M: Okay, I got--I got a good bit o' wood
B: (indiscernible)
M: Yeah, meet back up at the grassland.
B: Yeah, I'm gonna go back to the--
M: There you are!
B: OH MY GOD!
M: YEAAAAHHH!
B: It's you!!
M: Yaaaayyyy!
B: *relieved sigh*
M: *still cheering*
M: We did it!
B: We can finally
B: play this game!
M: We did it! :D
M: Ohhhh :)
M: I missed you SO much!--I don't have ANY grass.
B: *laughs*
M: *sighs*
B: What do you need grass for?
M: To build a ffire.
B: Here.
M: *Mark is relieved greatly*
M: And then....
M: thhhhabooski
M: YYAAAYYY!
M: OKAAAYYYY!
B: *laughing again*
M: We did it.
M: uuughh
B: *muffled* Ohhh god...
B: Jeez..
M: Alright...
M: So NOW...we got beefalo! Just like we told you we would! So...
M: THANK you everybody for believing in us, right Bob?
B: (Spooki)
B: *Silent thumbs up*
M: Okay, alright, okay, alright, okay, alright
B: Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. yeah.
M: So...thanks again everybody for watching, and then if you want more of this, we will continue in the beefalo forest
M: So thanks again,
M: 'n as always we'll see you *points at camera*
M: In the next video..
M: Buh-bye! *waves*
B: *waves*
(outro music playing)
Baby Mark: He he, he...Take THAT nature...
Baby Mark: Yeah, that's right, you tell that nature.
(outro music playing)
Baby Mark: It's been mean to you anyway.
Baby Mark: That's the.. Why is there a ceiling on the blood? "How the hell did so much blood get on the roof?" That is a excellent question.